[Música]
bailar bajo la lluvia no es más que
resilencia esa capacidad que tenemos de
adaptarnos a la adversidad así como la
palmera cuando viene la tormenta y dobla
su tronco baja su copa para luego seguir
el tronco fortalecido y alcanzar nuevas
alturas
antes de que hablemos del contexto
mundial quiero que lo llevemos a modo
personal y que cada uno dónde está
responde a estas preguntas
en los últimos 2 años han perdido seres
queridos
han pasado por un divorcio o una
separación
han enfrentado una nueva enfermedad
han tenido que cerrar un negocio o han
perdido su trabajo
tal vez la pregunta es alguien no se ha
empatado por la pandemia
difícilmente
y es que el 2020 con la llegada de la
pandemia profundizó la crisis económica
la crisis social la crisis de salud la
crisis ambiental
el hambre alrededor del mundo
para julio del 2020 teníamos
4.7 veces más personas trabajando desde
el hogar el trabajo invadió el hogar la
escuela invadió lugar tuvimos que
adaptarnos a nuevas formas de
interacción social y para octubre de ese
año el Foro Económico Mundial actualizo
el top 10 de habilidades para el futuro
en esta ocasión ya no para los próximos
10 años sino para los próximos cinco
años por la aceleración de los cambios
además ingresan a la lista una serie de
habilidades de autogestión es que nos
dice eso que tenemos que aprender a
conocernos para poder autogestionario
esas habilidades
ingresan la residencia
la tolerancia al estrés y la
flexibilidad como la palmera y hay
muchos estudios que nos dicen que es y
que no es una persona residente veamos
el estudio de la Universidad de Chicago
un estudio longitudinal de 2 años que no
dicen que las personas que no son
resilientes se victimizan
siempre esperan lo peor el cambio es
amenazado lo normal es el status quo la
vida la encuentro en sin sentido
aburrida
oscura
y de interpretación del estudio y mi
experiencia he visto que las personas
resilientes hacen tres cosas
uno no se aislan toman acción y
convierte en retos en oportunidades le
voy a compartir dos breves historias
para que ilustremos estas acciones
no aislarse y tomar acción
mi hijo Andrés tendría 4 años y va de
paseo un domingo temprano para la playa
con unos familiares y la persona que se
lo llevó se devolvió
porque se le olvidó algo donde yo vi el
carro regresar salía el otro beso de
despedida sin embargo no sabía que me
iba a enfrentar a uno de los momentos
mas aterradores de mi vida ver el carro
en el que mi hijo Andrés y mi sobrino
Gabriel iba cuesta abajo
sin control corrí
pensando posiblemente que era la Mujer
Maravilla que podía parar ese carro
y afortunadamente había un carro
parqueado lo roso cambio de dirección se
fue contra mi casa alivio temporal
la puerta del conductor se abrió y
Andrés alto el carro le pasó por encima
en ese momento quiénes tienen niños
pequeños en su vida saben probablemente
pueden entender la angustia que yo tenía
no tenía probablemente la claridad de
pensamiento ni podía manejar mi hermano
estaba ahí le pedí a mi hermana que nos
llevará el hospital más cercano en ese
momento en emergencias nos dijeron que
teníamos que hacer fila porque el niño
no tenía nada visible solo la marca de
la llanta en sus pantaloncitos y mi
hermana me dijo nos vamos al Hospital de
Niños
y ahí realmente la tensión y el amor que
le dieron a Andrés lo agradezco
infinitamente
hoy es un muchacho que salta pero en
bicicleta en las montañas de Arizona y
de aquí lo que les quiero pedir es que
cada uno piense quiénes son esas
personas que tienen su vida en mi caso
mis papás mis hermanos mis tíos mis
amigos cercanos y familiares cercanos
porque cuando nosotros entramos en
situaciones difíciles muchas veces no
tenemos la vista clara no tenemos el
pensamiento claro y estas personas nos
dan una perspectiva diferente en mi caso
mi hermana me dijo vamos al Hospital de
Niños entonces quiero que reflexionen
cuáles son esas tres personas de ese
círculo de confianza que usted tiene
ahora le voy a compartir la historia
sobre Fiorella una empresaria que se ven
pactada por la pandemia a la que admiro
profundamente que si no hubiera tomado
acción y no hubiera convertido los retos
en oportunidades sería parte de esta
estadística que nos dice que en enero
del 2021 en Estados Unidos se cerraron
110.000 negocio de bebidas y
alimentación se impactaron a raíz de eso
2.5 millones de trabajos
Fiorella está en Miami ella con dos
socios abrió un pequeño restaurante que
fue creciendo hasta tener 30 personas
trabajando en el empezaron a recibir
reconocimientos decidieron expandirse
sueño y entonces abrieron un segundo
restaurante
llegaron a tener 90 colaboradores todo
iba muy bien hasta que llegó el 13 de
marzo del 2020 y posiblemente muchos de
ustedes recordarán ese mes de marzo
diferentes noticias que recibieron la
angustia llego para ella tenía que
suspender el servicio de restaurante y
claro el balde de agua fría porque ella
decía y ahora como voy a pagar en la
planilla como voy a pagar proveedores
como voy a llevar el sustento a la mesa
de mis hijos
qué puedo hacer lo que entendió es que
no podía sentarse a esperar que pasara
la tormenta tenía que aprender a bailar
bajo la lluvia y así fue como Fiorella
decir buscar ayuda no solo para sus
restaurantes sino también para la gente
que trabajaba con ella se conectó con
otro dueño del restaurante crearon un
whatsapp donde se compartían información
de lo que va pasando pero además si a
alguien le faltan ingredientes de la
cocina ellos resolvían ella identifico
la oportunidad de vender el servicio
hacerle el supermercado a sus amigos y a
sus clientes también
tuvo la oportunidad de conectar con
personal de primera línea y vendréis
comida en un hospital cercano como ella
decía cada ingreso cuenta porque ella
paso de un buen día hacer 10000 $ en un
excelente día entre los dos restaurantes
a 150 de 90 personas a dos personas sin
embargo tomo acción y no se aisló y
además convirtió retos en oportunidades
y gracias a eso hoy tiene 70 personas
trabajando en los restaurantes están
abiertos funcionando y además espera que
para finales de este año que es
temporada alta volver al momento en que
estaba antes de que arrancará la
pandemia y todo eso requiere algo muy
importante
porque la autogestión de quiere ese
compromiso con conocernos a nosotros
mismos y yo quiero invitarlos a que lo
escriban puede ser tan corto como uno o
dos párrafos tan largo como ustedes
quieran cuando en el 2018 escribí mi
libro puse todo recordatorios
importantes en mi compromiso uno somos
como los árboles de Aspen
estamos conectados por las raíces no
estamos solos y dos elijo todos los días
la felicidad sobre el cinismo porque
debemos recordar que somos el frío o
director ejecutivo director ejecutivo de
la empresa más importante que es nuestra
vida que la gloria de la vida no reside
en nunca caer sino en levantarse cada
vez que caemos y ustedes que eligen
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]